The cubical represents a tyranny that confines
your imagination and thoughts are confined
to a small physical area.
Imagine pretty much every software engineer
or finance person being able to disconnect
from their desk and look at holographic monitors
on a beach and doing their work from there.
that’s not going to be science fiction
- it’s the modern office place.
Silicon Valley is all about building the future.
A startup called Meta thinks it’s getting
there first, thanks to a big bet it’s made
on Augmented Reality.
How are you?
Good, Thank you. Welcome to Meta.
Thank you.
Call it a 360 degree office where you can
spatialize your thoughts as part of your workflow
for education, architecture, design, engineering,
etc.
People often mix up Augmented Reality with Virtual
Reality.
VR totally blocks your ability to see or
hear the real world.
AR overlays holograms onto what you already
see.
Meta has tried to make its version of the
workspace feel familiar.
You grab the hologram, instead of using a
controller or a mouse and your brain already
knows how to do it.
In other words, we’ve designed an operating
system that
humanity has always known how to use.
So you can see this eyeball, which is, by
the why, photo-realistic.
You can see my hand is including the eyeball
and now the eyeball is including my hand.
Right.
See those two circles?
They get small and then they turn into this
glowing white ball and then I can move my
hand around super naturally.
I can do this with two hands and I can rotate
the thing, I can stretch it.
I can throw it back into the shelving system
and that’s all you have to learn to become
a modern worker.
And to prove this, the employees at Meta have
started to get rid of their computer monitors
-- trading them in for Meta’s augmented
reality headsets.
Meron thinks it will be less than a decade
before we'll all be wearing strips of glass
that can project holograms.
In the early 80s, everybody had computers
on their desktops but nobody was using them
because they had a lot of work to do.
So they were still using typewriters.
At some point the CEO took all of the typewriters
away and everyone was forced to use the computers
so it’s very exciting to see a new generation
of technology, a new paradigm.
I consider us like pioneers in the holographic
wild.
I’m, you know, pulling up my browser with
my hands and I’m sending out emails to my
colleagues and just kind of really acclimating
to the new environment.
Now you’re putting on my computer essentially.
Our digital lives live on our phones they
have all of our pictures and notes and things
- so why don’t you write yourself a little
sticky note.
Go ahead and take your first right over the
sticky note and close your fist.
And now….
What?!
Meta’s own transition to Augmented Reality
has run into plenty of unexpected problems
and it’s still gonna be a while before you’ll
start to see these devices in YOUR office.
But I think it’s a future worth waiting
for.
If we could see these holograms between us,
we will have been able to share our work with
one another more naturally, more efficiently
and more productively than ever before.
Humanity will have evolved slightly.